انا موظف يوان للاسف هم ما ارموش لا يوان
ولا اي مؤسسه دوليه كنت قاعد في الشقه هذه
انا واولادي طلع القناص من المنطقه هذا
جيت دبت المنطقه هذه بقول له انا رخيم
يعني انا بحكي عبري قلت له رخيم ببيت يعني
مدنيين في البيت ننزل يطخ علينا طخ اجت
سكترما في ابني وابن وابنت اخويا وكمان
واحد ثلاثه في المنطقه هذه قالوا لنا اشلح
وعيكم شلحنا واعنا ظلينا بالبوكسر نقلونا
على الغرفه هذه في معنا مصابين قلت له
هذول المصابين بيحتاجوا لعلاج قال لي انت
يوان قلت له صحيح قال لي انك يوان تعال
اخذني اربع مرات قابل معاي يقول لي انت
حماس وانا انا مش حماس انت وين بقيت في 7
اكتوبر قلت له انا في البيت قنت اجهز نفسي
اني اذهب للمدرسه روح على مدرستي قال لي
اولادك هذول قلت له هذول بقوا يجهزوا
نفسهم بدهم يطلعوا على جمعتهم للاسف ما
قعدنا يمكن ساعه وهم بينزلوا دمهم ونطلب
منهم مساعده بس عالجوا المرضى المصابين
بعد ك بساعه هم اي بعد ما تقريبا تصفى
الدم تبعهم نقلناه وبعد هيك بابي كانت
مزعه الاواعي قال بقيه دخلت لقيت اخوي
مستشهد ممين وطخينه قدام امه طخينه طلقه
في من المنطقه هذه راسه كله طالع فش دماغ
عنده قلت له ممكن اشوف اخوي قال لي ما قلت
له اخوي هذا قال لي لا يمكن طبعا المشهد
قدام ام مسك ايد امه وارتمى جنبها ودمها
ودمه طبعا
بينزل
ا